hello folks everybody doing today hope
you're doing fine
and you didn't get any virus out there
that's flying around apparently today we
have a great day and first of all I want
to remind everyone we have a conference
in Lusaka Zambia we've been advertising
this for a while so if you want to go
you got less than a month to pack your
bags buy your tickets and make your
reservation hotel reservations etc right
want to remind also people that we've
uploaded our book known as the rope
hypothesis and it's a free book you can
download it at rope hypothesis calm and
what it'll allow you to do is become
familiarized with what's happening in
this channel especially the rope model
of light and gravity okay it'll bring
you up the speed and it's a pretty easy
book to read I think it's heavily and
illustrated so it's free so if you're
interested in physics downloaded whether
you believe in it believe in the Rope
model of light or not you will get a
different view of the universe that's
for sure so if you want to be picked
your interest you know you want your
interest to be picked this is the right
this is the Right theory for that okay
and yeah we always ask anyone who can
translates got a second language to
contact us at okok acai at hotmail.com
and if you want to offer to translate it
we'll be glad to help you out whatever
the way we can okay okay
today I was again gonna talk about
something else but I had a lot of
comments a lot of criticism a lot of
questions and those need to be clarified
before we move on a lot of the people
that come here you know they they don't
know what the channel is about and so a
lot of things
that they here for the first time hid
them in their ears and they sent it or
in their eyes right and they said no no
something wrong there and it's because
they haven't been around enough to
understand what the channel is about
they don't know what the scientific
method proposed here is about they don't
know what science proposed here is about
we're known as rational science and that
distinguishes us from irrational science
which we have out there today if you go
to general relativity you'll find
nonsense such as black holes Big Bang
space-time four-dimensional space-time
unimaginable for that mental space time
you go to quantum mechanics you find
even more garbage you find particles can
be of two places at once or many at ones
place many particles at a single place
you'll have wave packets unimaginable
wave packet the particle itself is a
vibration of a field and so you have all
this nonsense with which the so-called
mathematical physicists purport to
explain the mechanisms mother nature
uses out there to run her shop and you
know this this is what we're criticizing
we have a rational proposal or a
rational alternative known as the rope
hypothesis with a rope we can explain
[Music]
magnetism gravity light electricity the
workings of the atom in the irrational
way what do I mean by that I mean that
we're gonna be using objects and we're
gonna make a film Illustrated for you
and you look at the mechanism you say
yes I understand because it's
straightforward so you will understand
it now whether you believe it or not
that's a separate issue but in the case
of quantum mechanics it's admittedly
admittedly by you know the people in
quantum mechanics among them Richard
Fineman Nobel Prize in 1965 saying that
no one understands quantum mechanics no
kitty
okay so today I'm going to address a lot
of the questions issues that came up
criticism objections etc and I'm gonna
start with one fella who put a comment
which I need to address first and he
said the following he said bill well I
say this right I say in my last video I
said now you can see why it goes slower
through glass into air I was talking
about light and that was an unfortunate
statement yeah and so he said I'm now
confused does that change color when it
goes through the medium or not please
clarify yeah when I said that what was
going through my mind is that wood came
out of my mouth okay I want you to know
that you're right in slapping me okay
what happened was I was thinking of the
mathematical physicists out there and I
was trying to say or what was what I was
thinking that didn't come out of my
mouth was this is why they conclude that
light goes slower through a medium
that's that's what I was thinking it
didn't come out right okay so yeah and
here you have it you know here's a rope
okay
rope and we have the wave equation C
equals lambda times frequency okay and
that means you're gonna change
wavelength for frequency or frequency
for a wave that's it those are the only
two variables one goes up one goes down
okay that's that's all if they're
inversely proportional so what does that
mean it means that if you have many
links like in this case when we have
four links there if you count the blue
ones
okay you got four links and if you
untargeted a then you have two links
okay two blue ones or rate maybe and
each link is longer dang and then vice
versa at you target and you have more
links each link is shorter and that's
the equation of a rope C equals lambda
times frequency wavelength times
frequency okay and that is the equation
so might always travels at the same
speed the other thing I want to clarify
about that is that you know the ultimate
hypothesis you the ultimate assumption
or a secondary assumption is the single
thread the single thread means that all
matter in the
universe is made of a single closed-loop
thread okay and you might ask and those
who are more familiar with the theory
again I recommend that people download
the book to know what I'm talking about
a little more right I can't go through
all the details right here right now but
those who are familiar with the single
thread they might ask well we'll bill
why did you choose why didn't you just
call your theory the thread hypothesis
and the reason is it's a secondary
hypothesis the main one is the rope why
because we're concerned about things
that are more close to us here on earth
which is you know like gravity magnetism
so we were to look at all these
invisible things that mother nature does
out there we want to try to figure out
how she does it what kind of magic or or
how does she do that okay and then the
Rope is appropriate because the Rope
explains light in one direction and
gravity and the other in a sense right
what you have is all atoms are
interconnected they're physically
interconnected by the electromagnetic
rope and that creates gravity and along
each strobe you have a signal going to
the other one so the Rope hypothesis a
better name for the for the whole
proposal then is the thread hypothesis
okay just want to clarify that
okay another comment that was made is
this one here up here hope I get the
right one no I got the wrong one
see that's what oh no it's it is the
right one sorry it is the right one when
fall says spatial frequency equals he
clarified this he said spatial frequency
equals the number of occurrences per
unit distance cycles per length interval
and he said on the other hand temporal
frequency is equal to number of
occurrences per unit time cycles per
time interval yeah and the only thing we
need to clarify on that is no one uses
the first one no one's uses spatial
frequency except when they're referring
to the vacuum light in a vacuum then
they use that but then every as soon as
light enters a denser medium
then they use the bottom one why because
they're gonna use the refractive index
version which is this temporal frequency
what happens is they're gonna maintain
frequency constant okay and what they're
gonna do is shorten the wavelength as
you can see on the top one on the right
we have the waves going through a
certain point in that line there that a
certain point that we are a bit weary
point and the one bottom the one on the
bottom also goes through that point at
the same time the only reason that can
happen is that the ones on the top have
to go faster they have to go faster in
order to catch up with the ones on the
bottom because the bottoms have less
length and so the other one the ones on
the top have more length they have to go
faster to make up the difference okay
and so the one they use again they don't
use the spatial frequency they use the
temporal one and and so I want to show
this which is what I mentioned last time
okay and that is that the refractive
index according to the mathematical
physicists is the one on the bottom the
temporal one what they do and I give the
example the color red there what they do
is they hold frequency constant and this
is just again an example 4.6 terahertz
okay so that's the frequency they're
gonna hold it constant when light enters
on denser medium in this case the
example is glass okay and what they're
gonna do is they're gonna play around
with a wavelength they're gonna shorten
the wavelength okay because the way they
visualize this is that the wave of light
is hitting a brick wall you know it's
the car hitting the tree okay so that
shock stops the wave it just flattens it
out in the direction of travel
okay which is what you just saw and so
they only play around with the
wavelength and one of the issues there
is whether you know
the color of light changes within that
new medium when within the denser medium
and that was what started this you know
the discussion because one fellow put in
there that the wavelength does not
change within the medium a denser medium
and I don't know where he got that he
there's many people who say the same
thing he just picked up on one of those
say oh look here it's proven and so yeah
that's that was part of the problem
that's where it started and yeah if
wavelength changes color changes because
color is a function of wavelength
and what these people are arguing is
that no no no color is a function of
frequency and so the answer to that is
yes to is as well right because it does
change in in relation to frequency
because again what we're talking about
is a rope and so if the wavelength
changes color changes but so did the
frequency you the wave equation C equals
frequency times wavelength cannot allow
any other possibility okay and on the
other hand refractive index is an
artificial table that they've created
based on pragmatic or empirical you know
experiments and did they see the way go
the WAV FLAC now did they see the
frequency etc no they didn't they
calculated that and they calculated it
because they said well hold it the the
wavelength had to flatten out because
light travels slower through that medium
and why did they pull around with a
frequency well you ask them that
question
they left frequency constant and they
just shortened the wavelength well with
a rope you can't do that okay
because if the links become shorter
right you get more links and vice-versa
if you untoward you get fewer links but
each link is longer and so there's your
frequency times wavelength which is a
constant
light travels at a constant speed
through any medium why because any two
atoms are connected by a rope like
architecture okay that's that's the
theory we're proposing and yeah so here
you saw the illustration of that you can
see that light waves are coming from the
left on your screen they're penetrating
this piece of glass okay which is the
blue in the center and then coming out
the other side and one of the issues
that people always ask is how is it that
the wavelength on the you know how is it
that light goes back to 300,000
kilometers per second when it exits the
glass that's a questions often asked and
people don't understand the mechanism
and so what the mathematicians had to do
was they say look the way flattens in
the inside the class but the frequency
remains the same and when it exits to
the lighter medium to air in this case
the wave goes back to its normal size
but this is all done you know
artificially what they're saying is the
wave flattens when it goes in and
lengthens when it goes out okay that's
what they're saying and another thing
that many of them say is that when it's
inside the glass it doesn't change color
even though the wavelength as you can
see is being flattened out in the
direction of travel so so these are the
issues that need to be resolved okay and
since we have some other questions I
think we're gonna be able to answer that
at these from our point of view here
today okay and here's the other question
or the other issue or criticism etc that
was brought up and we're gonna get to
that question I just asked okay mental
states that color is a function of
wavelength no I didn't state that okay
by me by this I'm saying not that I
disagree I'm saying that I'm like the
guy who states that this even before I
was born
everybody said that color is a function
of wavelength okay and
and so that's the first issue that needs
to be resolved but let's continue here
but that cannot be the case as the eye
has no way to measure wavelength listen
what he's saying he says the eye has no
way of measuring wavelength that's his
belief this is a this what he
understands or this is what it what his
experience tells him or what someone
whispered in his ear okay it must be the
frequency of light that creates its
color okay and so yeah the first thing
is I'm not the guy who said it I was
born in 1952 sixty-seven years ago and
before I was born we already had color
as a function of wavelength and I did
include because these people I don't
know they're they're not paying
attention so I'm gonna put it one more
time okay here it is
and it's the spectrum okay that's the
spectrum of light did I create the
spectrum no this spectrum has been
around for a long time the spectrum was
created by mr. Isaac Newton 17th century
long time ago like 400 years ago so
we've known about the spectrum since
that time when did we come up with the
notion that the that light is related to
color that color is related to
wavelength where did we come up with
that notion well we came up with that
notion from this gentleman in 1801 his
name was Thomas Young okay
and he wrote but he didn't write he gave
a lecture at the philosophical
transaction Royal Society in London he
gave it in 1801 it was published 1802
and II you know if you look up the
original source which is what I did here
you know you'll find that young printed
in other words over he published the
length of the waves there you see it in
the first column you know that triple oh
but for 402 sixty-six in terms of inches
okay then two five six two four six two
four oh two three five down
all the way to 167 at the bottom he
measured the wavelength of light 200
years ago and this fellow is saying what
he's saying let's see we he's saying
what we have no way of measuring wavelet
here we have a guy who 200 years ago
measured the wavelength you say oh my
god how could he have done that with
such low technology I mean it was he a
genius
oh yeah Thomas Young was a little
brighter than this fellow for sure you
know Thomas Young he's a caliber and he
mentioned very fine caliber right and he
did they did have microscopes in those
days as well you know by the way you
know today we have a seven we can see it
a lot better fact I have think a picture
here somewhere now look it up later
anyways here's a here's mr. Newton this
is where all started he started this
mess okay so you got to blame Newton for
this and what he did what Newton did he
he passed like white light through a
prism and you can see already that
within the prism okay this is a natural
picture okay the light is already
changing colors and when it comes out as
soon as it passes the interface with air
it's already broken up into colors of
the rainbow okay so so first of all it
shows that light does break up already
into colors within the denser medium
which destroys a lot of the notions that
people have out there and here's another
picture just in case okay this is a
different picture but again it shows
something similar okay you can see that
light goes through the prism and it
breaks up into colors within the prism
then it goes back into a second prism
which turns it into white light when it
comes out of the other end okay and you
can see a light is already breaking up
inside the prism so light does break up
within a denser medium and it better be
because the reason breaks up is it's
related to wavelength and as you can see
in the
that put this back up here the spectrum
okay you can see in the spectrum the
spectrum is based always on wavelength
nobody uses frequency and at least in
the industry everybody uses wavelength
in fact if you look just look up
spectrum okay don't take my word for it
look up spectrum and you will find that
everybody puts it in terms of wavelength
some people put it in terms of frequency
but 99% of the people put in terms of
wavelength and at the bottom you see my
version of the spectrum which is the
rope you can see the rope matches
perfectly with that so we have no
quarrel with the rope having longer wave
longer link lengths and matching with a
color spectrum okay so yeah why because
C equals wavelength times frequency is
the equation of a rope that's the wave
equation so called wave equation so the
equation of a rope in terms of the speed
of light little C is 300,000 kilometers
per second that's the speed of light I'm
saying that that one applies to the rope
other there are other equations for or
this same equation can be applied to
other types of ways okay so I want to
make sure that's clear but this specific
equation the velocity of light equals
frequency times wavelength is equation
of a rope there's no other possibility
you cannot mimic you cannot simulate
that equation with anything other than a
rope as far as I can tell maybe you can
do with a chain I don't know the coaxial
cable or wire I don't know but for sure
with but you can't do it with the wave
the transverse wave and you can't do it
with the particles particles first you
can't explain why a particle would go up
and down but takes the particle up what
takes it down and the wave there's no
such thing as a way way a stand you know
you don't you don't bring a wave a
transverse wave to the conference see I
can bring a rope and I can tell you what
my with light looks like it looks like
this as this kind of structured DNA
that's what it is
wave what do you gotta bring everybody's
gonna ask what is the wave made of
all transfers waves are made of
particles the ether that's it we're done
that means we're back to particles and
if it's particles you get explain what
takes the particle up and what takes the
particle down for that sine wave okay so
yeah that's that's the big problem at
weight theories will have okay and why
did this come about well one fella said
that light changes color remains the
same the color of light remains the same
going through a Bose Condon said
Einstein condensate and here he he
thinks that this was real that this was
a film of a photon so no this is this is
make-believe this is what you're looking
at is a cartoon and that's why the the
left of color in the step of light of
the photon they left it the same but he
thought he was looking at the real thing
okay so that's why I came about okay
another comment came up that was made
again your recounting of the official
version of white light slows in glass is
incorrect use a slicing okay the reason
is because light is an electric field
that affects the electrons of the
material in which it is traveling
causing the electrons to move as the
electrons woo they create an electric
field wave of their own which affects
pretty affects the light wave causing it
to move slower which is exactly what I
said so this guy wasn't paying attention
he just repeated what I said and since
he didn't say how it really works
in fact I Illustrated first first a lot
of these people send me to a video the
one that they all reference and that
video I did let's see if I get it right
where is it yeah this is the video and I
took this piece out and and you can see
it tells you there why light according
to mathematical physicists okay white
light travels slower through glass 2/3
slower and tells you there right there
here the Elector field is a combination
of light and the electric field of the
electrons so it's the electron field the
electric field of the electrons which
are slowing light down that's what I
said and so this guy wasn't paying any
attention so who knows what went through
this tiny brain okay he should pay more
attention in fact I Ellis trated here
you see the illustration you see light
waves coming in from the left they go
into the glass and those red that red
waving that's supposed to imitate the
electron the electron field so light
affects the electrons in the atoms they
create waves and somehow those waves
slow the piece of light that goes
through the glass and what is it doing
it's shortening their wavelength that's
what's happening okay it allows the
frequency to continue without any
problem but it shortens their wavelength
and if you still have problems believing
that then what we do is we show you that
what is written in the Wikipedia and
what everybody essentially says this
piece comes from the first to come from
the the stack exchange the first two
comets and the third one from the
Wikipedia they all say the same what
flattens is the wavelength
it's the wavelength that's like what's
flattening it the field of electrons
which is waving it's waving why because
supposedly the the waves of light hit
the atoms of the glass so it shakes all
the electrons now the electrons are all
shaking right and creating a wave and
that wave interferes with a smooth
passage of light slowing it down what
does it do it flattens the wave length
of light and so light travels slower
according to mathematical physics not
according to me through the glass when
it comes out since the electrons are no
longer there to vibrate it continues
back or returns back artificially by
magic wand
though because there's no reason why why
wouldn't it not remain flat after that
why would it expand again to a normal
wavelength what takes it back to a
normal wavelength that's what you got to
explain see if the piece of glass
shortens the wavelength within the glass
right of light right why would that
wavelength expand again once it goes
back to air I mean please explain the
mechanism and of course they will not be
able to explain the mechanism either in
air or in the glass because there is no
such thing as a wave wave theorists are
people who have mental problems because
there is no physical standalone object
called wave a wave in the ocean is made
of water wave of a flag is made of cloth
what is the electromagnetic wave made of
in other words you have to identify not
the movement which is the wave you have
to identify the object in this case it's
the ether obviously that's that's what
everybody's thinking but nobody mentions
it okay but yeah so this is the issue
the issue is that I did explain exactly
the new version in this for the third
time I think I'm explaining but a lot of
people are quite dense and they're not
following through that they're not
understanding what's in front of them
what's visually in front of oh okay okay
another comment here's the comment I
like this one I think invisible ropes
are things objects all other hypotheses
are conceptual and do not exist because
no one has ever defined existence so
sayeth mophead muppet this is like
watching an episode of Gilligan's Island
when the professor's love boring ginger
and Mary Ann you're a [ __ ] I'm going to
get a copy of your book just so I could
burn it on video absolutely love the guy
okay
another guy says waves are in fact
objects waves are objects uh-huh and
another one says since you're vehemently
against concepts what is magnetism an
object so you can see all these fellows
you know the
they haven't been around they don't
understand what we've been saying in
this channel at all and it's it's like a
hit and run they just came in listen to
something that offended them and they
just say oh I'll show you yeah okay so
what are the problems with these well
the problem is that these people you
know don't know can't define the word
object that's the problem okay so here
it is let's put theirs back up so we
have next one right next to another
what's the issue the issue these people
don't know how to define these two words
object and exist and physics is the
science of existence physics only tries
to explain those things that exist with
things that exist so you have to make an
assumption especially about the
invisible intangible mediators that
mother nature uses okay that's that's
the issue you have to use your common
sense and say well how can mother nature
be doing this magic trick and of course
if they're intangible and untouchable
you're not gonna figure this out through
experiments and which is what these
people have in their mind they're saying
let's go to the lab and see it we can
see and touch it okay and and yeah if
physics is the science of existence only
objects may be said to exist okay
because the definition is exist is equal
to physical presence object that has
location and you can't do physics
without an object so yeah these are
mandatory definitions to do physics and
these people want to skip the
definitions as you can see no one
defined it they just say oh you know
it's like we know what the word object
means and we know what a thing is we
know what exists means but none of them
defined it and they can't and they won't
because no one has done so in 10,000
years why would these tiny brains do any
be any different okay so this is the
issue the issue is you got to define
okay
and here's another comment along those
same lines and this fellow time also got
a little upset
apparently this channel offended his
religion raped his virgin as I say okay
I love how you demand in physics objects
be made out of something physical no but
okay let's continue but you never tell
us what your so-called ropes of light
are made all out of and see he's
focusing always on made out of okay why
is that I mean they're obviously not
literal ropes made out of right yep
fibers or nylon right so what are your
ropes of light made from okay it's
always made me if you can't tell us then
I guess we can just discount them as not
existing oh the bird the word exists why
do we always bring that into these
conversations we always bring what an
object is and what existing means and
for those of you who've been around you
can see that these are the key words
that everybody's going to use you can't
avoid it and physics everybody's gonna
talk about whether wave is an object and
whether it exists whether particles
exist whether space-time exists whether
black hole exists is it an object object
that exists object that exists object
that exists you can't avoid those words
and see and nor does he define either
object or exists okay every rope I've
ever seen I could touch okay great and
Bend and tie in knots and physically
interact with so if light is a rope you
should be able to show us show ya here
I'll show you
here's the rope okay I showed okay I did
the show part show and I'll do the tell
later by taking a light beam and tying
it in a knot for us
uh-huh we will wait here for you to post
the video of you tying light in a knot
okay
also how does a rope of light pass
through a solid piece of glass I mean
I've never seen any rope that could pass
through a solid except perhaps as a
magic trick is that how it does it magic
[Laughter]
okay let's answer in this fellow what's
the problem with all this well the
problem is he never defined a word
object okay that's that's the problem so
we don't know what he means by object
but he insinuates not formally defined
but insinuates that it has something to
do with touch and with see and also made
of he's talking about what does it made
out of okay well what is it made of or
what
and we've already discussed that okay
and obviously he hasn't been around
enough and they're you right there in
the middle you see the word made of the
term a dog yeah none of these can
service criteria for defining an object
for the purposes of physics this is not
ordinary speech this is not what we
think of normally in the streets about
the word object or what a thing is what
a medium is what an entity is now here
we have to define a very stringently as
that which has shape okay and so yeah
you see see touch and made of made of we
call me rheology mariely DG is religion
anyone who has what is it made out of is
talking about religion that's what it is
damn and so yeah what we have is what we
call the golden principle and the golden
principle what is it you can't do
physics without an object so you must
define the word object how do we define
it that which has shape now do you see
any provision for made of do you see any
provision for C do you see any provision
for touch in that definition and
hopefully you don't because that which
has shape has nothing to do with C with
touch or with made of is a table what
it's made of is that what a table is you
know here comes the the Martian you know
a Klingon comes to visit us here on
earth and he has what is the table well
is that the table is a gazillion atoms
Oh
what is an elephant well that's a
billion atoms uh-huh what is a house
that's quadrillion atoms
that's what they're made oh is that what
an object is what it's made of so what
are the objects what are these atoms or
things that make up these big things
aren't those objects to an object is the
object is made of is that what the
definition of the object should be is it
that which you can see is it that which
you can touch or we can't see the air I
mean does that eliminate the air as a
physical object not in physics may be an
ordinary speech but for the purposes of
physics air is a physical object water
is a physical object you said what do
you say
you mean air is a physical yeah because
you're bringing your notion of ordinary
speech for the purposes of physics there
had better be an object because first
it's made out of atoms but forget about
that because that's the made of
definition we're talking about air as a
body or water as a body okay when we say
why don't want me to say here and all
you got to do is have the astronaut you
know put water in a little balloon right
take it out there in space stick his
hand outside the window it's his
spaceship blow it up right and something
you see this blob of water you know just
expanding in space right and someone
might say well you know that's an odd
shape I don't know what is the shape of
that that's the wrong question
the question is does it have shape it's
a yes or no type of question we have to
ask whether God has shape or whether God
does not have shape if God does not have
shape God is a concept and that's what
you're praying to a concept hopefully is
listening if God is an object because he
has say well then at least you you have
something that could exist if it has
location so yeah water is a physical
object and water does you know that blob
of water that the astronaut release that
has shape and so does the air that he
would put in a balloon if we could see
it if we could call her coated he pops
the balloon in the middle of the space
that blob has shape and we call that
blob whatever shape it tasted we don't
care if that that blob has shape and
here on earth yeah we have the shape of
beer and it has a shell shape enveloping
the earth so air does have shape yeah
it's a yes or no type of question does
air have shape yes if it has shape it's
an object period for the purposes of
physic we're not talking about ordinary
speech here you can keep your ordinary
speech in your Sunday school don't bring
it here okay and and yeah and so here
was this thing that this other fellow
said you know he said oh we can film see
here here's
proof that this guy is asking he's
saying look here we film the photons
right they're going right through the
air and they're going through that blob
there and going slower through the blob
and so we filmed the photons well if
they filmed the photons you can be
absolutely sure that they have not
filmed light and the same goes for this
fog he says bring it over here
show me that that you that you can tie
the rope in knots the rope of light
right in not well he's only defeating
his own argument but he's not smart
enough to realize that because what he's
saying is that here mother nature made
something which is untouchable unseeable
of smellable untestable unhearable and
he's going to go to the lab and he's
going to try to prove that you can't
touch light and you can't see light well
yeah we know that
but if he's successful or if I were
successful or if I could go to the lab
and say look I tied the rope in knots
you can be sure the Rope is nonsense
then because you know we're not supposed
to see or touch the rope okay because
those are not that's not the definition
of an object is that which has shape and
a rope has shake and so does the
architecture of the medium that serves
as a mediator for light the agent the
secret agent that mother nature uses if
I could touch if I could see that
mediator if I could tie it in knots as
this guy says for sure then the rope
cannot be the mediator of light because
mother nature specifically made it
invisible and intangible because if she
had made it tangible
we'd be tripping over all these ropes
not to mention if he made them visible
we wouldn't see anything other than
ropes in our eyes
so yeah see touch is not the right
criteria but these people are stuck on
this see touch thing and they say oh how
can how can a rope go through each other
don't they get tangled and and the
question is why did they ask that about
I mean quantum says look all these
particles go through each other you can
have many particles at one location at
the same time you can have one particle
at two places at once nobody questions
that nobody asks that question over
there
nobody says how can two particles be at
one place at once
how can one particle be at two places at
once okay so like President Kennedy once
said he said ask not how rope and cross
against another through another how two
ropes can occupy the same space ask how
two particles can occupy the same space
or be at two places at once that's
that's what Kennedy said okay so that's
what you should address you should worry
about you know explaining quantum first
before you come here and talk about the
rope if you can do with quantum
explaining how two particles can be at
the same place at the same time or how a
particle can be at two places at once
two places yeah two different places at
once fine then you can start asking that
question about the rope first first
let's answer quantum so we make sure you
don't return the quantum number again
okay let's make let's make sure we cross
out that possibility first okay here is
another comment and says the ether is
not a bunch of particles again people
are offended because I define ether as a
bunch of particles another person says
the ether is a world is a world used to
identify the medium that fills
everything for sure cannot be bumping
particles see none of them tell you what
the ether is everybody just tells you
what it ate and that should make you
stop and wonder you know why don't these
people define you know what what ether
is and so I had to define it for them
now you find it as a bunch of particles
and here I made you know here you have a
vision of what the ether has always been
what everybody has always understood by
the ether except people who never
worried about the Phoenicians who never
did any investigation on the either they
just use the easy you know they just run
along within they said well these
there's a bunch of waves and a bunch of
particles and who knows what concepts
are in there no no no no the ether has
always been a bunch of particles it's
always been treated as a bunch of
particles specially in the 19th century
which was the century of ether until it
died supposedly died at the beginning of
the 20th century and all they did was
really convert the ether into space-time
and a false vacuum and all these other
fancy words that they have today for the
ether because ether is still around
that's the problem and here's the ether
okay see if I can put it in here give me
a second
somehow I lost my ether there where I go
okay I got another ether no problem give
me a second here's the infinite ether
okay the infinite ether occupies the
entire universe it has no end
okay and if that's the case then the
ether is not an object because an object
is that which has shape and this one
doesn't have shape I only have shape now
me because I had to put a square around
it but otherwise this thing is
supposedly what they call infinite and
there's no such thing as an infinite
object because an infinite object
violates the definition of the word
object an object is that which has shape
and this thing doesn't have shape
because it's infinite right so there is
no such thing as an infinite object okay
so here's the finite ether in the
alternative okay that's the infinite
ether you can choose to have this one
here's the finite ether so we have ether
and somehow there's this black stuff
whatever that is that continues and of
course you have to identify the black
stuff we don't care about your your
ether your particles there we want to
know what the black stuff is what are
you gonna put in there and one of the
problems that we have with the ether is
that people wanted two ways and they
don't understand this so you so I try to
make them pay attention but they don't
so this is only for intelligent people
people who are not intelligent you don't
listen to what I'm gonna say next okay
just get out and this is the issue is
space a container it is space a
container you know like a box or a
cylinder where you put gas or something
like that is space a container the space
contained particles or is space made of
particles we have to clarify that so the
guy who comes in with a proposal of
particles of ether he has to tell us
one or the other is your space is your
vacuum is your nothing made of particles
which is what quantum mechanics says
yeah that space is made of particles
photons primarily that's what they have
in their mind or the space
particle meaning that space is something
else and it contains all these marbles
in there you got to clarify this and see
they they never do they never you can't
pinpoint them because they run away
everyone runs away so that's the
question they have to answer is space
made of particles and or is space or the
space contain particles the space
contain marbles but because then in that
days they have to tell me what spaces
they have to define the word space or
vacuum or nothing or whatever they want
to call it okay so this is the issue and
you know until that is question is
answer we can't continue because we're
talking to your rational people okay
okay here's the ether in terms of waves
because some people say no it sways okay
here's your waves here's the infinite
eats are made of waves this time okay
and again it's not an object because
because if if it were an object it would
not be infinite okay and so then we have
to make the ether
you know the finite ether now we have
again this black stuff that surrounds
the ether ethers in there and that's
we're inside that universe where you see
all those waves we need to know what the
black stuff is that's what we need to do
and in that case you got to tell me what
the black stuff is and if it's a
container or if it's made of waves or
you know particles or whatever and this
is the issue the issue is that all these
people elude these tough questions no
one pinpoints of stays two years
analyzing ether what is the ether okay
and they say rather they they you know
Lu Han Wei B and they just want to
continue and say I'm gonna use the ether
no no I don't want you to use it I want
you to define or point to it if you're
gonna point to it I need for you to
illustrate it and it better be finite it
better and then in that case you got to
identify what encapsulate the ether what
that black stuff okay so these are the
issues that all these people avoid okay
okay here's a here's another fellow
moving on here and he brought a comment
from mr. Newton he said some choice
quotes
of Isaac Newton and I've not gone
through all not going to go through all
the details here you can look at it
later you know but essentially what
Newton emphasized were hypothesis the
word hypothesis shows up a lot in his
language okay he talks about certainty
which is an opinion means that you have
certainty you believe you have proved it
to yourself talks about experimental
philosophy has nothing to do with
science not not the philosophy part but
the experimental part we don't do
experiments in science because we cannot
first of all we don't do experiments
because we have to explain experiments
not do them anyone can do an experiment
I can drop a pen a hundred times
it's a repeatable experiment I can
measure and does that mean I can explain
why the pen falls to the floor okay so
this is the issue the issue is
explaining that's where you have to
break your head but to describe and say
yeah I dropped the pen a hundred times
that did the experiment and so what what
did you learn that's the issue and so
experiment have nothing to do with visi
aside from the fact that experiments
will not tell you what light is
okay expect we did all the experiments
we ever needed to do about all mother
nature's invisible mechanisms we did
experiments on how electricity on
magnetism and light on rabbit we did
them all I mean maybe there's one
experiment we we forgot when in more in
the in the in the bag of marbles maybe
there's one more marble in there okay
fine maybe we missed one or two we did
all the experiments we ever needed to do
we don't need to do any more experiments
we need to explain now we need to know
what gravity is we need to explain what
gravity is we need to explain the
mechanism of gravity what mother nature
how mother nature does that trick and
this is what these people don't
understand these and all the student
experiments go to the lab let's go to
the field let's do it run another
experiment for what what are you gonna
run we're done with the experiment
the experiments can we we have to
explain what we observed you know you
like observation okay we already
observed everything yeah now we need to
explain
you know why a pen falls to the floor
very simple experiment just you can do
it at home always in the presence of
erogenous right let go of a pen you'll
find out it falls to the floor do you
did the experiment it's a repeatable
experiment anyone in the universe anyone
in planet earth for sure can do it now
explain it explain why that pen foster
the floor not to the sky not to the
ceiling and hopefully you will not use a
concept called mass or another concept
called force or any other nonsense
invented by mathematical physics now
what you have to do is explain it in
mechanical terms you have to hopefully
you're using objects and not you know
spirits and angels in God you know magic
now you get explained with objects you
need a mechanical explanation you need
to illustrate you make it need to make a
movie of how mother nature does that
experiment or that phenomenon and that's
the problem
the problem is that Newton was a very
influential person but she in the
following century in the 18th century
until he died I think twenty seven
nineteen sixteen twenty seven sixteen
rights seventeen twenty seven seventeen
twenty eight something like that but he
was very influential even after death so
that's the problem because he among
others you know another one was the
Galileo they insisted a lot on
experiments on math and none of that has
anything to do with science science
explanations we don't use math to
explain okay
you can't explain with math you can only
describe with math so yeah unfortunately
Newton took us on the wrong path and
that's why we have very little respect
for Newton ok another comment and this
one shocked me a little bit if two
objects were identical spheres shapes
and they were attracting towards each
other would they accelerate because I
don't see how the ropes could fan out it
wrote me struck me because this is this
is something we should all be able to
visualize and so what I did was create a
little give here see if I can find it
here
where is it there it is always have so
many of these sometimes they're hard to
find and so here you see it okay you
have two balls equal size
these balls are made of atoms okay let's
make sure we understand it every atom of
one ball is connected to every atom of
the other ball I only put two ropes
they're two connections it doesn't
matter if they're rows whatever I just
put two connections okay
and what an object is attracted to
another now I just want you to look at
the angle of the ropes you can see that
the angle changes and if you put a
gazillion ropes between them you're
gonna forget between every atom of one
object and every atom of the other
you're gonna see the same you're gonna
see all these ropes you know just
changing their angles so they're not
pulling on the same axis okay and yeah
it's up to you to put all the other
ropes in there I need to take the time
but with this if you can't visualize
this well you know I can't help you this
this is straightforward as far as I'm
concerned and here's another version of
it which is what I explained I think one
or two videos behind before and it's an
astronaut falling to earth and here you
can see the ropes as a false they're the
ropes
fan out so I'm not sure what is so
difficult to understand about the
mechanism that is being proposed by the
rope model the Rose fan out as the guy
falls to earth okay because every atom
in his body is attached to every atom
that makes up the earth okay so I don't
know I can't help you any further
if you can't visualize that well I'm out
of luck okay just wanted to cover a
couple more points one is that mr. tan
amaura the other day I brought him up he
claims to have handled one electron out
of time okay he did the slit experiment
with electrons with electricity
essentially right and he claims the
second guy to claims oh another guy who
was an Italian group but led by a fella
by the name of merly
and years later this guy came out no no
I was the first one and so he handled
one electron at a time so sees so he
says okay and this is what he said I
pointed this out the other day okay he
just went in and shot these he says you
can be sure these are individual
particles these electrons he shot him
one at a time and yeah anyone who looks
at this yeah it looks like he shot him
one at that time right because look look
how that he's building all that up so we
have a lot of problems with this the
first one is you know did he did he I
mean he's pretty good shooting you know
he's he's got this gun and he's gonna
shoot on the screen and he's gonna put
each bullet exactly where he needs it
you know that's that's pretty good
shooting I mean you try to do it at a
shooting gallery or you know somewhere
where they have guns and you have a
target try to see if you can hit them in
such a way that you build these friends
just like he like he did it here see
you're gonna build that shooting one
electron out of time you know that's
this that's kind of hard to believe that
he did that by pointing I mean no two
electrons fell on the same spot he built
that one atom at a time one one electron
at a time
you know how did he do that and
especially the the issue is you mean the
electrons just fell in such a way that
they built these fringes one at a time
why did all these electrons fall in the
same spot okay that's that's one issue
but then then the other more important
more basic is the electron the electron
is alleged to be a zero dimensional no
volume nothingness there is no such
thing as an electron and here's proof
those people who want proof okay see if
I can find it here here's the electron
it's called the no size electron as I
call it okay and what do you read there
and that's what you're gonna find
electrons are is this from the wikipedia
says electron generally thought to be 11
3 particles because they have no known
components for substructure in particle
physics an elementary particle or
fundamental particle is a subatomic
particle with no substructure thus not
composed of other particles ok then you
look up another version it says when our
electron looks more like a particle it
has no shape according to the standard
model in this context physics is called
an electron a point particle ok meaning
that it interacts as if it is entirely
located at a single point in space and
does not spread out to fill a
three-dimensional volume and when you
look up point particle says oh particle
is an idealization of particles heavily
used in physics yeah maybe in religion
it's defined features that it lacks
spatial extension being 0 dimensional it
does not take up space so how did mr.
tano Mora handle a nothingness known as
the electron right he says he handled
one electron at a time maybe he handled
spirits maybe he pushed angels I mean
how does he know he handled one electron
time when they say that it's got no
volume it's got no no size we're talking
about the zero nothingness that's what
it is and he says he handled one of
these at a time but then we have a
bigger even more fundamental problem
with tano Maura's version and that's
here it is the planetary atom you know
he's in order to handle one electron out
of time this is what he relied upon he
relied on the orbiting bead model of the
atom he's saying electron is that little
bead that's going around atom and he was
able to manipulate that little bead well
you know it's like I said last week what
they have to do is
Tamura and all the quantum mechanics is
to draw a picture of the atom all I need
to see is an atom okay and here's what
they need to specifically draw which is
what we're interested in and that's that
brown stuff there we need to know what
is between the electron and the proton
or the nucleus if you prefer what holds
the electron what binds it to the
nucleus why does the electrons stay
there before he handles it and uses it
to do ionization or electricity we need
to identify that that region there okay
now Donna Morra claims that you know
there's no other possibility of
interpreting what he did except shooting
one bullet at a time and again we
challenge that see if I can find it here
there it is and your there is another
mechanism and it's the bullet versus the
drill did he shoot bullets at the wall
or did he drill holes into the wood I
mean which one did he do is is the
bottom one are valid mechanism also for
doing electricity or should we just say
that electricity is the shooting of
bullets and again if he's gonna do
shooting a bullets he's got a deep he's
got a first ella straight the quantum
atom and he can't do that because what's
he gonna put between the electron and
the nucleus that's that's the question
that he's gonna have to answer before he
can make a claim that he handled one
electron at a time okay and here you see
the different notions of electricity
that are out there okay the first one is
the you could call it the classical
mechanics that means that you have atoms
and you have all these electrons flowing
from atom to atom what quantum has done
is gotten rid of the atom itself and it
just shoots electron beads and they say
electricity is just a flow of beads
electrons and that's what Connor Moore
is saying he's saying that you know
every electron he handled individually
and he can play around like playing with
marbles you know he can handle this and
push it any way he wants and what is the
problem with that well the problem with
that is that if you're going to do
electricity you know now we're quite a
few quite a few years in in this field
if you have a vacuum chamber and you
pump it down we pumped it down usually
to 5 to the minus seventh or and there's
hardly any material in there there's
quite a bit really as we found out
always there's quite a bit of material 5
times 5 times 10 to the minus seventh or
okay but for all practical purposes
that's a clean chamber that's pretty
clean chamber what we do next is we fill
the chamber with argon and inert gas and
when you do that now you raise the
pressure back up to the minus 3 tor
level so you were at room pressure right
you bring it down to 5 to the 5 times 10
to the minus seventh or now you bring it
back up to close to room pressure in
other words that minus 3 to our luck
will you go back right because you put
more garbage in there you're gonna put
argon in there right and now you can
have electricity flowing at minus 3 tor
level you do have electricity flowing I
swear on my mother's grave okay you do
have electricity flow you have that
situation now pump the chamber down you
pump all the argon out little by little
gradually and you don't put any more
argon in and so you're gonna vacuum the
team back again you're gonna pump it
down so you're gonna go to a - four -
five - six - seven tour hopefully you
can continue all the way to minus 12
which is what we have on the moon and
the question is will electricity
continue flowing when you do that when
you remove the atoms okay I mean you
would think that now electricity should
be easier the electrons have nothing to
block their passage
okay so now the mean free path of the
electrons going from cathode to anode
should increase okay and so now you
should it should be easier to run a
current and that's exactly not the case
it's the opposite you need to raise your
voltage the more material removed from
chamber the more voltage you need to get
that electron bead supposedly right to
flow across the vacuum to the anode and
so that defeats quantum mechanics
because quantum mechanics says that if
you remove matter from the chamber the
electricity that's the prediction that
would be the prediction using that term
that quantum mechanics uses the
prediction should be that now
electricity should flow smoother because
now you removed all the obstacles
because you don't need atoms in the
religion of quantum mechanics all you
need is to send beads through the vacuum
and that's not true that's definitely
not true don't take my word for it go
out there and verify with any guy who
does vacuum and you'll find out that if
you remove matter from the chamber you
have to increase the voltage but if you
leave voltage constant and you remove
matter from the chamber the electron
beads will laughs flow you will not have
electricity flow okay don't take my word
for it just go out there and do your
research you'll find that that's the
case okay go over the line a little bit
this time around and just want to leave
you with this thought which is also
related to the atom what does an atom
look like and it's got to do with the
quantum numbers okay quantum numbers
essentially you have the principal
number the magnetic number and the
azimuthal number and these are numbers
that give you an idea of what you know
when you apply them to Schrodinger's
equation it gives you the shape of an
atom I can give you the s orbital which
is a spherical orbital it can give you
the p orbital which is the figure-eight
orbital right you get all these or
by simply plugging this into
Schrodinger's equation that's why he
became famous because he was able to
give you an idea what an atom looks like
based on this equation okay
in one sense that was pretty good work
no doubt about it so you get a situation
that looks more or less like this
see if I can put this up here takes a
little bit to get these things up here
okay
let's see if I can get it up here okay
so you can see when an atom might look
like in reality in this invisible world
of atom if you apply Schrodinger's
equation to those numbers including one
that's missing which is the spin I'm not
going to get into that today okay but if
you apply those and you put them there
that's what that would be the shape of
this invisible thing we call atom okay
that's one type of atom here you get a
whole series of them okay get this up
here okay you can see the shapes as you
apply Schrodinger's equation so we are
able to see this invisible world of
atoms by simply applying Schrodinger's
equation okay now how does a rope handle
this okay that's that's the point that
I'm trying to make so that you can take
it for your own thought okay here's
here's the rope model okay let me put
the first one back up there quantum
numbers here it is okay we're saying
essentially the same thing here okay
we're saying that what Schrodinger
discovered is not the not the movement
like the angular momentum or the
different Z and and x and y directions
of angular momentum
he thought he was describing an electron
bead that is moving around in a region
around the nucleus and what we're saying
is that the electron is really the whole
shell that encapsulates the proton and
Schrodinger's equation really does it
does give us the shape no doubt about
that book what it is it pinpoints a
point a location along the sphere in
this case the hydrogen atom right that
encapsulate the proton okay
so all these numbers are applicable to
the rope model just as much as they are
to the quantum model which is the
orbiting bead right which again Dean
can't justify why the electron stays
tied to the proton in our case we have
no problem because the model of the rope
shows that the threads one goes to the
center of the atom which is the nucleus
which is the proton in this case and the
other one coils around and forms the
elect the electron the it's really the
electron shell that's what we call it's
a shell and and so the numbers that
quantum uses the azimuth the magnetic in
the principle these are simply locations
that the mathematicians are pinpointing
along that shell okay so yeah we do have
a version of what are known as quantum
numbers and again this is just for your
food for thought so that you can apply
the same equation to Schrodinger's
equation with all the quantum numbers
you're gonna plant just as well to the
rope model no problem whatsoever so not
only can we apply the wave equation to
light but we can apply quantum numbers
which underpin Schrodinger's equation we
can also apply them to the rope line
okay with that I will see you on
Wednesday
and we'll see you then and download the
books for free go ahead and read it and
it'll bring you up to speed on the Rope
model different universe you don't have
to believe it we only ask that you
understand it we'll see you on Wednesday
bye buddy